So Gabriel Stirling is the voting implementation
manager with the Georgia secretary of state's
office, and he has had enough of Trump and
went off yesterday during a public statement
telling Donald Trump that he's gone too far,
that election workers are being threatened
and targeted in Georgia thanks to the things
Donald Trump has been saying and that Donald
Trump must stop inspiring his followers to
be violent right away.
Check out these videos.
And again, this is a lifelong Republican,
Gabriel Sterling, who works for the Republican
Georgia secretary of state, saying Trump has
gone too far and he is complicit in the harassment
and targeting of poll workers and other election
workers in the state of Georgia.
It all gone too far.
All of it.
Joe DiGenova today asked for Chris Krebs,
a patriot who ran Cesa to be shot, a 20 something
tech in Gwinnett County today has death threats
and a noose put out saying he should be hung
for treason because he was transferring a
report on batches of items to a county computer
so he could read it.
It has to stop.
Mr. President.
You have not condemned these actions or this
language.
Senators, you have not condemned this language
or these actions never have.
I mean, he says Trump hasn't condemned it,
Trump has encouraged it.
We're like a few layers removed.
Certainly there hasn't been condemnation because
Donald Trump has been encouraging this behavior.
And again, just a reminder, this is a lifelong
conservative Republican, Gabriel Sterling,
voting implementation manager with the secretary
of state in the state of Georgia.
Georgia, of course, one of the states that
Donald Trump lost to Joe Biden, but insists
that he actually won.
Let's see a little bit more video here.
As the secretary said yesterday, people aren't
giving you the best advice.
What is actually going on the ground?
It's time to look forward.
If you want to run for reelection in four
years, fine.
Do it.
Put everything we're seeing right now.
There's not a path to be the bigger man here
and stop.
Step in.
Tell your supporters, don't be violent, don't
intimidate.
All that's wrong is un-American.
The Republican Party owns the crazy right
now.
But when you have one guy like this who says
enough is enough, he instantly gets attacked
by Trump ists.
Here is Gabriel Sterling essentially explaining
stochastic terrorism.
I don't he doesn't he's not using this term.
And I don't think he even recognizes that
he's doing it.
But he's he's effectively doing it.
When Gabriel Sterling says some people, because
Trump has so many people that listen to him,
some people will hear the stuff he says, and
someone could do something violent and Donald
Trump say so check it out.
And, you know, there are people who can be
have some righteous indignation to be angry,
but there's also people out there at this
point in the social media world, we see what
happens.
There are some nut balls out there who are
going to take this.
As the president told me, to do this.
Essentially, you have to be responsible.
You have to be responsible in your rhetoric.
You have to be responsible, your statements.
You have to be responsible in your deeds.
That shouldn't be too much to ask for people
who asked for us to give them responsibility.
This is really the crux of stochastic terrorism,
which is the idea that given a big enough
audience, it starts to become likely and probable
that if a media figure plans a certain idea
in the minds of their audience, if there's
you know, if you attack someone every day
on your show and your audience is 100 people,
it's not super likely that your attacks will
motivate anybody to actually go and try to
kill that person as an example.
But if your audience is a million or ten million
or, you know, 80 million, is Trump's audiences
on Twitter, including certainly some bots,
but OK, 80 million roughly, even if it's only
a one in 80 million chance that somebody will
hear what you say and go and attack someone.
Once you have 80 million people that are listening
to what you say, that starts to become probable
and likely.
And that's essentially what Gabriel Sterling
is referring to here.
And of course, he's absolutely correct.
He's saying the right thing now.
At the same time, Gabriel Sterling has been
part of the machine in Georgia that has been
suppressing the vote in ways Republicans believe
are advantageous, trying to suppress the nonwhite
vote, trying to suppress the non rich vote
for a long time.
And you've got a lot of people now holding
up Gabriel Sterling as some kind of hero because,
look, he Republican takes on Trump right now.
As far as we know, he's taking on Trump because
his friends are poll workers and it's all
about protecting his friends.
And it's not really about running for election,
I don't know one way or the other.
But the point is, he's saying the right thing
in this instance.
He may be saying it for the right reasons.
He may not.
But Georgia is one of the worst places in
the country as far as voter suppression is
concerned.
And Sterling's been part of it for a long
time.
He's been part of it as a worker, as an employee
of the secretary of state's office.
He was previously a right wing councilman
in Georgia.
So as much as he's not trying to stop a problem,
he's identified he's been a part of the problem
for a very, very long time.
Broken clocks can still be right every once
in a while.
I think this is one of those examples.
Trump doesn't care.
And he immediately this guy becomes enemy
number one for the Trump ists who believe
because Trump keeps saying it and some Fox
News hosts keep saying it and so do others.
For the people that believe Trump really did
win, Joe Biden really did steal this thing.
This isn't going to make a difference.
But needless to say, it's very interesting
to watch